der wesentliche unterschied zwischen
vorurteile und diskriminierung ist doch
die soziale macht auf unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen ebenen und ich will
es wichtig dass wir das im blick
behalten und der so genannte alte weiße
mann wird nicht im hinblick auf seine
weise diskriminiert er wird block
schickten mich hat nicht die
schlechteren zugang zum arbeits oder
wohnungsmarkt beispielsweise oder zu
bildung und das müssen wir unterscheiden
damit wir in dieser debatte voran kommt
das was wir heute hier machen darüber
diskutieren ist super ich finde seine
debatten toll das hätte man nur im
politischen raum auch mal vorher machen
sollen und das ist nicht passiert
[Musik]
wie rassistisch ist unsere gesellschaft
2020 vor allem nach den ereignissen rund
um den mord von george freut dass diese
frage so präsent wie noch nie es gab
hunderte demonstrationen auf der ganzen
welt tausende menschen haben sich
solidarisiert mit der black lars metter
bewegung das sind wir uns überhaupt
einig darüber wo wir ansetzen wollen im
kampf gegen rassismus genau darüber
wollen wir hier heute diskutieren mit
den menschen die da gerade hinter mir
stehen und natürlich auch mit euch hat
deutschlands polizeiapparat ein
rassismus problem brauchen wir das
berliner anti diskriminierungsgesetz
vielleicht in ganz deutschland oder
brauch ist ganz andere mittel um gegen
strukturellen rassismus in deutschland
anzukämpfen
herzlich willkommen bei 16 fragen jetzt
machen wir die erste runde das ist eine
schnelle runde ohne worte sagt erstmal
nicht miteinander diskutieren ich habe
ein paar thesen für euch und wenn ihr
diesen thesen zustimmt dann geht ihr auf
das grüne feld
wenn ihr diesen thesen nicht zustimmt
dann geht ihr auf dasselbe feld erste
these für euch nicht nur die
amerikanische polizei hat ein rassismus
problem auch die deutsche zweite these
das neue berliner anti
diskriminierungsgesetz schützt menschen
in berlin vor diskriminierung durch
behörden
es soll klagen zum beispiel gegen
polizistinnen erleichtern
dieses gesetz sollte in allen
bundesländern eingeführt werden
die anzeige von der polizei gegen die
person die die taz kolumne geschrieben
hat ist ein angriff auf die
pressefreiheit
das antidiskriminierungsrecht in
deutschland ist super schwach
ausgestattet und deswegen ist es sehr
sehr stark und toll dass es in berlin
jetzt ein eigenes anti
diskriminierungsgesetz gibt und dass
menschen sich jetzt beschweren können
wenn sie diskriminierung auch in
staatlichen einrichtungen erfahren zum
beispiel auch in vielen schulen des
landes antidiskriminierungsgesetz
versucht ansprüche von personen die sich
diskriminiert fühlen durchzusetzen wir
halten das für nicht notwendig oftmals
hören wir dass menschen davon ausgehen
dass rassismus nicht strukturell ist
tatsächlich sind das in der regel
menschen die rassismus nicht selbst
erfahren und entsprechend keine
vorstellung davon haben dass rassismus
auf allen gesellschaftlichen ebenen
bedeutsamen lassen ich finde wir haben
eine der besten polizei der welt
natürlich gibt hier und da probleme aber
wir können uns fehlt
glücklich schätzen dass wir in einem
land leben wo ordnung wo gesetze
herrschen wo die polizei ein wirklich
helfer ist freund ist ich glaube die
polizei hat ein problem mit ihrer
fehlerkultur und mit der art und weise
eigenem fehlverhalten konstruktiv vor
allem in die zukunft gerichtet
konstruktiv umzugehen ich bin ja klar
bekennender gegner dieses gesetzes und
setzte auch alles daran dass in der
nächsten legislaturperiode auch wieder
abzuschaffen
aber ich bin natürlich offen für
argumente und freue mich auf die
diskussion und auf das spiel alles klar
jetzt nicht man schon
wir haben zwei fronten ich mache direkt
weiter mit der zweiten runde mein ziel
natürlich heute ist es bestenfalls euch
alle hier wieder ins mittelfeld zu
bekommen hier will ich euch am besten
nachher alle wiedersehen bestenfalls
finden wir heute kompromisse beginnen
wir aber erstmal mit den fakten für euch
wir haben das allgemeine
gleichbehandlungsgesetz agg und den
artikel 3 im grundgesetz der die
gleichheit vor dem gesetz garantiert das
reicht doch eigentlich aus oder wenn ihr
nicht zustimmt bleibt einfach stehen
wenn er zustimmt kommt er einen schritt
auf mich zu
[Musik]
das stimmt nicht so warum na weil das
allgemeine gleichbehandlungsgesetz
nichtdiskriminierung beinhaltet die
durch staatliche institutionen ausgehen
und das heißt wenn kinder in eine
staatliche schule gehen was einfach mal
die meisten kinder in deutschland tun
und dort diskriminierung erleben dann
greift dieses gesetz gar nicht und diese
lücke schließt das landes
antidiskriminierungsgesetz und deswegen
braucht es ist auch josef martin indyk
beide hier stimmt dem zu ja auf jeden
fall
ok keine bewegung auf der seite dann
richte ich mich jetzt an euch
es geht nun speziell um die
polizeibehörde auch polizistinnen werden
zu tätern und täterinnen forschungen an
der universität bochum ergeben dass es
jährlich bis zu 12.000 rechtswidrige
übergriffe durch polizeibeamte gibt und
damit fünfmal mehr als in der
offiziellen statistik erhoben wird seid
ihr der meinung dass das eine zu hohe
dunkelziffer ist und ist es nicht
dringend an der zeit die arbeit und die
strukturen bei der polizei zu
hinterfragen wenn ihr dem zustimmt kommt
jetzt gern ein schritt auf mich zu und
wenn nicht bleibt bestehen
ok du grinst warum und sogar und darum
reihe zu stehen weil das ist keine
anerkannte studie ist die du da gerade
zitiert hat der hersteller hat etwas
aufgeschrieben und man muss sich immer
mal angucken wie sowas zustande kommt da
konnte jeder mensch einen vorgang
eintragen der meinung wo er der meinung
waren die polizeimaßnahme war nicht
rechtmäßig da konnten auch polizisten
tragen ist wo die überhaupt nicht
überprüft
es ist in der tat so dass es sicherlich
ein dunkelfeld gibt aber das sollte man
dann auch sauber wissenschaftlich
untersuchen und ich glaube dass die
polizei in deutschland speziell auch in
der hauptstadt definitiv so weit sind
dass sie ja auch keinen zweifel daran
lassen dass du das transparent
untersuchen
ich frage mich warum wir eigentlich nur
über die polizei sprechen was ist
eigentlich die politische haltung da
hinten natürlich gibt's rassismus
erfahrungen dieser gesellschaft
natürlich müssen wir besser agieren und
berlin hat unglaublich viele baustellen
die der senat hat viele baustellen um
gleichberechtigung zu schaffen in dieser
gesellschaft aber was tut die polizei
sie geht nicht grillen mit den menschen
die hat das gewaltmonopol das staatliche
gewaltmonopol sie geht in grund fliegt
situationen das sind keine einfache
situation
und jetzt durch so eine anti
diskriminierungsgesetz die arbeit der
polizei so beeinträchtigen dass sie
ihren auftrag nicht erfüllen konnte es
enorm schwierig es sind keine einfache
situation ist gibt auch rassismus
erfahrungen der polizei
aber ich sehe keine strukturen die dazu
fuhren und die stehe nicht dass eine
bestimmte gruppe benachteiligt weil sie
zu einer bestimmten gruppe gehört ich
arbeite auch bei der polizeiakademie und
ich sehe wie heterogen die gruppe ist es
gibt viele menschen mit
unterschiedlichen politischen
einstellungen natürlich gibt's einzelnen
die nicht dazugehören obwohl sie kommen
nicht nur vor recht sie kommen auch von
anderen extremistischen ecken
das muss besser werden aber diese
generalverdacht gegenüber die polizei
und diese missverständlich für das was
die polizei im alltag tut und in welcher
situation sie gehen muss kann ich nicht
verstehen
ich würde ganz gerne was zu dieser
studie sagen also es ist ein generelles
problem bei dunkelfeld studien dass
natürlich menschen auch anonym gefragt
werden und das ist immer ein bisschen
unsicher
ich kann nicht erkennen
leider dass immer dann wenn es zu
übergriffen kommt oder oder
unrechtmäßigen polizei verhalten die
polizei damit konstruktiv unten geht
insofern würde ich schon sagen ja das
ist ein dunkelfeld zu vermuten dort und
ich würde mir wünschen dass es eine
studie darüber gibt ich finde auch die
polizei kann es sich wünschen
also ich hatte mir viel früher so eine
studie gewünscht aber ich hatte erst mal
fest ihr seid euch hier uneinig ihr sagt
die dunkelziffer ist nicht so hoch und
es gibt kein strukturelles problem bei
der polizei das verändert werden muss
ich richte mich jetzt wieder an euch
tatverdächtige können durch das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz nicht nur die
schulbehörde oder beamten im
gesundheitswesen sondern auch die
polizei anzeigen und auf einfachem wege
die alltägliche arbeit verkomplizieren
vielleicht sogar die strafverfolgung
erschweren die verwaltungskosten könnten
durch das gesetz enorm steigen und die
exekutive lahmgelegt werden
stimmt ihr zu das gesetz ist
vergleichsweise neu und im vor jetzt zu
dem zeitpunkt zu sagen
dies könnte geschehen und das könnte
geschehen und gehen es könnte geschehen
das finde ich ein bisschen zu sehr
ehrlich gesagt in die glaskugel geschaut
wir auch jetzt schon kurz einschalten
dürfen also kann ich dir sagen das wurde
am vierten juni beschlossen im berliner
senat das ist noch nicht mal in kraft
getreten und schon in den ersten wochen
in den ersten tagen noch am selben tag
gab es bereits vorfälle die das handeln
auf der straße verkomplizieren
erschweren einfaches beispiel ein mann
packt in einer verkehrsberuhigten zone
sein maserati ab weil er weiß im bistro
essen bilder was kommt ein
polizeibeamter hin und spricht ihm
darauf an rente schnell zu seinem auto
möchte auspacken und hinter ihm steht
ein rollerfahrer hat er dann nicht
geschafft und in der diskussion hat ja
immer wieder auch den kollegen
vorgeworfen hätte diskriminiert mich
hier nur weil ich dunkle haare habe das
kommt vielleicht gar nicht dann zur
anzeige aber es war kompliziert jetzt
schon die vorfälle
ein anderes beispiel da hat jemand eine
biertischgarnitur auf dem gehweg
gestellt und der kollege musste am ende
weil es eine ordnungswidrigkeit deswegen
einer bloßen ordnungswidrigkeit muss der
viereinhalb seiten bericht schreiben
weil auch die person ihnen vorgeworfen
hat dass er in diskriminieren würde also
es ist in der täglichen praxis schon
eine verkomplizierung das kriegt man
vielleicht nicht mit und wir werden nach
einem jahr
vielleicht feststellen es gibt keine
klagewelle ja es muss auch nicht gleich
so klar gekommen das sagen wir auch gar
nicht aber es war kompliziert die arbeit
könnt ihr diese angst vor der
verkomplizierung verstehen die angst vor
stehen schon und ich bin wahnsinnig
wichtigen punkt als das allgemeine
gleichbehandlungsgesetz eingeführt wurde
hat sich die gesamte wirtschaft dagegen
gestimmt und es wurde der untergang des
abendlandes beschrieben weil jetzt
arbeitgeber nicht mehr selber
entscheiden können wen sie einstellen
und dann funktioniert das alles nicht
mehr das land geht unter also ich glaube
ein großer respekt versorgen gesetz hat
durchaus in teilen seine begründung ist
aber auch also zeigt ja diesen
fortschritt und natürlich ist das nicht
okay wenn das jetzt wirklich die arbeit
total lahm liegen sollte aber dann muss
man nachjustieren
aber das heißt ja nicht dass man
deswegen nichts macht oder irgendwie den
leuten nicht die möglichkeit gibt sich
unabhängig über die polizei zu bestellen
oder unabhängig über behörden zuständig
da hätte ist nur das gesetz nicht
gebraucht der berliner senat plant auch
ein bürger und polizei beauftragten oder
wie immer man ihn nennt da ist das
schulwesen mit drin das ist eine
unabhängige beschwerdestelle außerhalb
soll diese stelle geben dann muss der
berliner senat normal aus den puschen
kommen es ist schon längst ein entwurf
da und da stimmen wir uns auch überhaupt
nicht gegen ist doch super eine
unabhängige stelle können sich im
übrigen auch polizisten dran wenden und
mal missstände anklagen ohnehin
dienstweg einzuhalten
da ist dann nicht eher die frage zu
überlegen wie kann
diskriminierungsschutz gewährleistet
werden und wie kann das funktional sein
für die polizei ja natürlich das hätten
wir gern vorher gemacht wir haben unsere
bedenken angebracht die hat nur der
justizsenator völlig abgeschmettert das
was wir heute hier machen darüber
diskutieren ist super ich finde so eine
debatten toll das hätte man nur im
politischen raum auch mal vorher machen
sollen und das ist nicht passiert
vermissen entscheidender punkt weil weil
du vorhin sagt ist das gesetz wurde
davor schützen ich weiß aber die
ideologie die dahinter steckt und die
zielrichtung und die zielrichtung ist
aus meiner sicht ganz klar ideologisch
geprägt hat der menschenrechte oder ein
die ideologie ist da ein instrument zu
schaffen um gegen die polizei zu
arbeiten und deshalb bin ich da so
skeptisch und auch gegen dieses gesetz
ist die frage warum nur polizei und das
war eine panne habe ich im griff eine
verachtung das ist der verachtung
staatliche gewaltmonopol
doch das ist bei bestimmten
politische richtungen vorhanden warum
sind dann sämtliche
migrantenorganisationen in berlin dafür
also wenn du spricht es hat ja auch
wenige migranten und eigentlich müsste
das was anderes ist nun auch ein
gewisser politischer haltung haben und
sie kommen einfach ein bild politische
richtung kommen natürlich aber wenn ich
das einbahnstraße ist und nur in eine
richtung geht dann dafür ich auch diese
vermutung haben dass es eine gewisse
politische haltung dahinter ist
migranten kremmen auch politisch damit
es keine einbahnstraße gibt habe ich
sehr sehr viele fragen werden wir all
diese punkte gleich nach ruhe
ausdiskutieren können
ich will aber noch mal kurz festhalten
ihr seid euch in vielen sachen natürlich
noch nicht einig und das ist total klar
weil deswegen steht ihr da ganz links
und ihr steht da ganz rechts ich halt
noch mal fest wir sehen wenn man es noch
keinen schritt aufeinanderzubewegt
vielleicht ja jetzt an euch innerhalb
der deutschen polizei gibt es
rechtsextreme gruppierungen stichwort zu
stichwort nordkreuz rassistische gruppen
und todeslisten mit den namen tausender
personen des linken spektrums wurden
gefunden und die polizei muss sich den
vorwurf gefallen lassen von rechten
strukturen unterwandert zu sein und muss
dagegen massiv vorgehen
beispielsweise müssen polizei
bewerberinnen in dieser hinsicht
strenger geprüft werden
stimmt ihr zu holen aber das hat nicht
nur das hat nicht nur mit
rechtsradikalismus ohne sie gleich
setzen zu wollen wir haben auch
islamistische fällig wir haben auch
andere nationalistische ideologie bei
der polizei das muss vor allem in berlin
in meine arbeit merke ich das muss viel
besser werden und das ist in anderen
bundesländern wohlgemerkt noch teilweise
viel schlimmer es ist wichtig gerade das
thema auch politische bildung neben
ethik beispielsweise eben auch wirklich
immer wieder in aus und fortbildung und
das war dann weil wir natürlich in
unserem land und davor verschließen wir
uns nicht wir haben auch eine politische
partei die mittlerweile im bundestag
sitzt die hier auch gerade um polizisten
polizisten wird mit falschen versprechen
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass auch
immer wieder hoch zu halten
und ja es gab diese fälle ja wir haben
keinen strukturellen rassismus in der
ganzen deutschen polizei es gab diese
fälle und die leute noch niemand es
werde nur falsch jetzt von diesen fällen
auf alle zu schließen aber
nichtsdestotrotz muss man hingucken
ich würde gerne eingehen auf dass das
gerade gesagt ich finde es total
spannend ich würde gerne nämlich noch
einen punkt auf greifen weil ich den
eindruck habe wir können ganz lange
diskutieren aber ich glaube dass wir
sehr unterschiedliche vorstellungen
davon haben was wir unter rassismus und
vor allem aus strukturellen rassismus
verstehen weil es geht für mich
überhaupt nicht darum zu sagen es gibt
dieser ein paar menschen und die sind
böse sondern ich finde der aspekt der
gerade aufgegriffen worden ist nämlich
unsere bildung und die art und weise wie
wir groß werden wie wir sozialisiert
werden ist strukturell rassistisch
deswegen gehe ich gar nicht davon aus
dass die polizei per se sozusagen
schlecht ist und alle menschen der
polizei per se absichtlich auch was ist
das handeln sondern ich würde das ganz
klar differenzieren wollen wir sind auf
eine bestimmte art und weise groß
geworden und mit bestimmten
wissensbestände sozialisiert worden
und die finden sich natürlich auch bei
der polizei wieder und auch bei jenen
die nicht absichtlich rassistisch
handeln wollen und ich glaube das ist
auch die frage vielmehr vielleicht auch
welche unterstützung sozusagen kann
angeboten werden und genau da auch hin
zu schauen
du sprichst von struktur der rassismus
und ich sehe das nicht ich sehe keine
prozesse ich sehe keine gesetze ich sehe
keine mentalität bei der polizei die
strukturell zu rassismus vor
und das ist mein problem damit das ist
rassismus gibt ist ja und zwar mussten
wir darüber reden warum nur bei der
polizei gesprochen werden die gibt es
überall die gibt es in den schulen gibt
es bei lehrer die gibt es überall aber
diese prozesse diese gesetze
diese anweisungen innerhalb der polizei
zieht zu struktur gehört die zu
rassismus und diskriminierung führt die
sehe ich nicht
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt müßig dass
wir uns darauf versteifen dass es als
würde es nur um die polizei gehen aber
das ist ja absolut nicht der fall
explizit wird im lbg angesprochen auf
diverse einrichtungen des kirchen kann
ich nicht nachvollziehen warum wir jetzt
sozusagen uns darauf versteifen wurde
wieder warum reden wir niemand hier
redet nur über die politik gerne bereit
zu reden das ist nicht die kuppel wieder
aus stahl war was kommuniziert weil ja
gerade polizei arbeit leitet leidet das
neue album nach einer woche schon zu
sagen die polizeiarbeit leidet ist ein
kleines bisschen verfrüht da nicht
wichtig was nicht an jetzt schonmal
garnicht lichkeit die polizei
unterschätzt wird mich macht ehrlich
gesagt stutzig dass du sagst in der
berliner verwaltung wenn man jetzt mal
die polizei nicht so im fokus nimmt gibt
es ein strukturelles rassismus oder
diskriminierungs problem
das wurde in der konsequenz bedeuten
dass sämtliche führungskräfte auf allen
ebenen dies sozusagen goutieren auch die
politische leitung nicht einschreiten
würde und auch dagegen nicht arbeitet
weiß nicht ob sie das jugendamt neukölln
bremm rassismus sondern also das was ich
aber das meinte diese fing gerade dass
wir ein bisschen verschiedene
verständnis haben vom gleichen begriff
und dass ihr wahrscheinlich deswegen
auch nicht so gut auf einen nenner
kommen übersteige bedeutet doch
organisiert da gibt es eine struktur die
gewachsen ist und gegen die niemand was
tut und sorry also da würde ich mich mit
allem was ich habe verwehren dass in
meinem jugendamt die kollegen die mit
schwierigen familien zu tun haben
strukturell und ich das dann auch noch
akzeptiere strukturell diskriminierend
arbeiten also aber vielleicht kannst du
das erklären mal ganz kurz samstag denn
genau den begriff einfach kurz klären
sodass besser da josephine möchte einer
früheren was was macht den strukturellen
rassismus aus was ist dass ich sekunde
das verständnis dass rassismus
strukturell ist bezieht sich zunächst
einmal darauf dass rassismus unabhängig
davon ist auf eine vermeintlich gute
oder böse absicht haben ich bin darauf
gerade schon ein bisschen eingegangen
wir sind in einer gesellschaft
sozialisiert die rassistisch
strukturiert ist das heißt zum beispiel
historische aspekte sind bedeutsam die
tatsache dass deutschland eine kolonie
hatte oder diverse kolonien besser
gesagt die sonne für natürlich nicht
aber es irgendwas ist ja genau der
aspekt auf den ich gerade eingehen
möchte das heißt es ist über individuell
es geht nicht um dich persönlich es geht
nicht um dich persönlich oder um dich
persönlich
es geht auch nicht um mich persönlich
oder ihm um ihn oder um sie sondern
worum es geht ist dass wir in einer
gesellschaft groß geworden sind auf der
auf unterschiedlichen ebenen in unserer
gesellschaft rassismus wird das wirkt
einerseits im zwischenmenschlichen
miteinander zum beispiel wenn ich mich
in dieser zeit schwarze personen und
andere leute sich von mir weg setzen
weil sie vermeintlich angst haben ich
sei besonders kriminell
das wird natürlich auch auf der
institutionellen ebene durch regeln und
maßnahmen beispielsweise die das
begünstigen auch wenn sie das gar nicht
absichtlich wollen warum natürlich auf
der strukturellen ebene beispielsweise
in der vorstellung dass zum beispiel
schwarze menschen und menschen auf carla
besonders kriminell sind und diese ebene
wird natürlich auch auf unsere
sozialisierung und diese wissensbestände
und das weiß ich natürlich auch
insbesondere aus meiner arbeit finden
sich überall die finden sich natürlich
über
auch und schulischer bildung die finden
sich in film und fernsehen gesehen wie
radiobeiträgen worauf hinaus möchte ist
also es geht nicht darum ob sie eine
persönlich gute absicht haben oder einen
persönlichen negative absicht sondern es
gibt wissensbestände die wir immer und
immer und immer wieder reproduzieren und
die frage ist doch vielmehr wie können
wir damit umgehen welche möglichkeiten
haben wir sozusagen mit diesem wissen
beständen umzugehen
welche möglichkeiten haben sie unsere
verantwortung zu übernehmen wenn wir
sagen wir wollen für gleichberechtigung
uns einsetzen weil dafür müssen wir erst
anerkennen wo eben gleichberechtigung
fehlt ich möchte nur sagen ich weiß
nicht ob rassismus auch in unserer
gesellschaft in meiner alterskategorie
springt knapp über 30 auch noch so ein
thema ist wie es vielleicht im
alterskategorie 50 60 also du hast
gesprochen von strukturellen rassismus
der also mitgebracht wird über die ganz
ehrlich ich habe in meinem leben nie in
unterschied gemacht und ich habe viel
auch mit anderen menschen zu tun hat ob
es beim sport des ob es in der schule
ist ich bin übrigens auch dozent an der
hwr das ist der andere studien weg von
der berliner polizei
auch in meinem kurs bin ich mir jetzt
schon sicher dass ich vermutlich alleine
weil ich das heute und die mitnehme
wahrscheinlich ein kollegen der nachname
hat der vielleicht nicht nur deutsch ist
wie immer man das auch bezeichnet den
werde ich glaube ich nicht eine
schlechtere note geben soll ich bewerte
die nach leistung
du hast das erklärt den begriff struktur
ein rassismus würdest du denn der
aussage von benjamin zustimmen dass er
noch nie einen unterschied gemacht hat
zwischen menschen nein warum genau
deswegen weil es eben nichts ist was uns
bewusst oder sondern diskriminierungs
die normalität und nicht die abweichung
und ich glaube das ist wichtig dass wir
das verstehen aber das macht nicht nur
benjamin das mache jeden muss genau das
ist hier aber der punkt natürlich bin
ich nicht nur weil ich so zu einer
rassistisch wie privilegiert bin im
hinblick auf alles andere gleichermaßen
schlecht gestellt nein sondern auch ich
bin ja mit wissensbestände groß geworden
die dazu führen dass natürlich auch ich
sozialisiert bin auf einer art und weise
dass ich bestimmte menschen nicht
mitdenken und genau das ist ja ein
wesentlicher aspekt das heißt noch mal
kurz zurück zu kommen zum eigentlichen
thema nämlich dem landes
antidiskriminierungsgesetz er geht es ja
zum beispiel und ferner hatte das
eingangs gesagt unter anderem darum dass
zum beispiel wenn es eine behörde gibt
und eine person mit rollstuhl ist nicht
in der lage diese behörde reinzukommen
dass das bemängelt werden kann um mehr
geht es erstmal muss das
und immer auch warst ja aber der
wesentliche punkt das ist nämlich genau
die sachen sind die wir nicht mitdenken
und das ist es wo wir hinschauen müssen
all die sachen die wir eben nicht mit
böser absicht mache ich glaube ein punkt
würde ich schon gerne entgegen kommen
wollen
irgendwie ist dieser dieser vorwurf der
ideologie des polizei hat es im raum
also so würde ich das raus und ich komme
damit nicht so ganz klar weil das das
wovon ich rede ich glaube wir auch ist
das thema diskriminierungsschutz und
nicht angriff auf polizisten also das
ist eine völlig verdrehung der der des
ziels dieses gesetzes oder das ziel
überhaupt dieses themas also unter
welcher bedingung kommst du einen
schritt berliner polizei ich weiß wie
die formulierung aber so ungefähr dass
sie sich mühe gibt und dass sie das
thema rassismus und auch vielfalt in der
universität auf dem schirm hat da würde
ich schon mit ok dann an wenn sich auch
möglich würde ich unterschreiben ich
bezweifle aber dass der berliner senat
dieses eingelagert und ich möchte mal
können wir gleich sprechen jetzt muss
man wirklich zur nächsten frage in monza
dass wir genau diese kontrollen nicht
angesprochen haben weil das ist ein
thema auch weil er einer polizistin mein
polizei nur ganz kurz mit einem
polizisten der aufgrund von hautfarbe
jemand kontrolliert macht seine arbeit
falsch das ist ein falscher weg
also ich darf jetzt die dritte runde
eröffnen die dritte runde funktioniert
so dass ihr alle persönliche erfahrungen
natürlich habt persönliche geschichten
und die könnt ihr jetzt miteinander
teilen und gerne natürlich auch damit
versuchen euch gegenseitig zu überzeugen
dafür haben wir jetzt zeit ist kam hier
gerade schon das stichwort welche
profiligen der optik hat schon
angefangen darüber zu diskutieren
josephine ich möchte gerne die anfangen
was sind denn deine erfahrung wenn du
sie teilen möchtest mit racial profiling
mal abgesehen davon dass ich in einem
bezirk lebe in dem die tatsächlich auch
relativ viel polizeipräsenz ist und ich
natürlich sozusagen auch aus zweiter
hand immer wieder miterleben wie zum
beispiel verdachtsunabhängige
personenkontrollen stattfinden
insbesondere bei schwarzen menschen und
menschen auf color ist es eine erfahrung
die ich tatsächlich auch selber gemacht
habe als ich mit dem zug gereist bin und
als einzige schwarze person kontrolliert
worden bin im hinblick auf sozusagen
meine persönlichen daten und das ist
eine erfahrung die mache ich natürlich
normalerweise auch in berlin im übrigen
ich glaube tatsächlich auch dass es in
dem polizeigesetz gesetzgebungen gibt
die begünstigen das racial profiling
stattfindet ich glaube die große
problematik in deutschland ist das ist
ja keine offizielle these deswegen weiß
ich nicht um neue reifen drauf ich mich
bewegen würde so darfst dich bewegen
warum warum stimmt zudem nicht zu sehr
hat er gerade eine sehr persönliche
geschichte erzählte der schon mal wenn
sie die erfahrung gemacht hat aber sie
hat gesagt dass die polizeigesetze
irgendwelche puff heiligen stützen oder
unterstützt vom günstigen begünstigen
und das glaube ich nicht
ich würde gerne gedanklich noch kurz ein
jahr weitergehen weil ich glaube dass es
insbesondere auch für deutschland
bedeutsam ist in deutschland gibt es
keine sinnvollen daten dazu die erhoben
werden zumindest nicht offiziell
und das ist wirklich wichtig auch
festzuhalten inwiefern racial profiling
eine realität ist ich weiß dass das zum
beispiel in großbritannien anders
gehandhabt wird weil ich glaube
tatsächlich dass es ganz wichtig ist du
hast das eingangs gesagt auch im
interesse der polizei wäre solche daten
zu haben um überhaupt oft in der lage zu
sein das real verneinen zu können
solange es solche daten nicht gibt finde
ich ein grundsätzliches verneinen
problematisch stimmt ihr dieser aussage
auf basis von josephine persönliche
erfahrungen
und gar einen schritt auf sie damit habe
ich ein problem weil ihre persönliche
erfahrung die die schockieren mich die
machen mich traurig und ich bin
natürlich zustimmung geben
aber diese schlussfolgerung von der
persönliche erfahrung auf die
struktureller ebene von rassismus das
lehne ich ab das sehe ich nicht jeder
erfahrung mache ich absolut mit
natürlich die habe ich auch teilweise
gemacht und die lehne ich ab ich will
eine gesellschaft leben wo alle gleich
und ich würde mir die ganzen wünschen
dass die polizei die deutsche polizei
das unterstützt also dass sie solche
forschung zulässt oder selber
durchführen lässt
aber wären das nicht reichen punkten
sonst ansatz auf dem man sich einer zu
scheint es so dann plötzlich doch gern
wir genug gute statistiken vor allem von
der natürlichkeit ebenso eine studio
also tun um gesperrt sich doch keiner
dagegen aus seiner persönlichen sicht
was muss denn für die institutionen die
polizei getan werden
zunächst mal ist glaube ich
grundsätzlich wir haben wenn das die
rassismus definition ist haben wir ein
problem mit rassismus in unserer
gesellschaft ja das ist nichts was
allein die polizei betrifft ich glaube
dass hier konsens so hoch danke man muss
glaube ich grundsätzlich davon ausgehen
dass wir alle menschen respektieren
sollten ja der respektvolle umgang ist
sehr wichtig hier fragt ja auch nach
persönlichen erfahrung also ich bin ab
und zu bei einer demonstration dabei ich
werde jetzt nicht selbst diskriminiert
ja aber ich sehe dann kollegen die dort
die versammlungsfreiheit schützen ist ja
auftrag ja und die schützen und die
schützen vielleicht auch mal eine
npd-demo die wollen das nicht die
schützen nicht den inhalt sondern ich
schützen die demonstration und dann hört
man darum herum leute die wir wir
sollten als demokraten alle
antifaschisten seien aber die dann laut
brüllend antifa und und dann bringen die
ihre nazis was schützt ihr da so und
dann nimmt der kollege mal den helm ab
wusste nicht glauben wie doof wie alle
gucken ja weil dann steht eben nicht der
alte weiße man das idealbild eines
polizisten was vielleicht immer noch
viele konstruieren so ist die polizei
nicht mehr die ist vielfältig aber man
grenzt auch man diskriminiert polizisten
weil sie polizisten sind ja wir führen
gerade eine debatte darüber und wir
führen diese debatte nicht über
strukturellen rassismus im schulwesen
die führen wir nicht
es ist eine öffentliche debatte über
strukturen rassismus in der polizei
berichtet mich wenn es anders ist aber
dass führende gerade diese debatte
müssen wir gerade führen warum weil es
die pole
sei es sind polizisten von sich aus
keine menschen mehr dürfen steinplatten
auf sie geschossen werden wenn du mich
fragst was man für die polizei tun
sollte na ja man sollte erstmal kennen
dass es menschen sind die in der polizei
sind seid ihr damit der chor ich habe
gesehen ich glaube jeder ist ein schritt
nach vorne gegangen haben wir etwas
erreicht ist doch auch schön dass ich
ihn was denkst zu dem was benjamin
gesagt hat ich kann noch nicht so
richtig nachvollziehen warum gerade der
punkt stark gemacht worden ist dass
menschen bei der polizei
menschen sind weil davon gehe ich offen
gestanden aus ich glaube auch nicht dass
das hier heute irgendwie zu irgendeinem
zeitpunkt infrage gestellt worden ist
deswegen würde ich das vielleicht so ein
bisschen außen vor lassen wollen
ich finde aber trotzdem wichtig und das
ist mir wirklich auch wichtig das zu
verstehen
der wesentliche unterschied zwischen
vorurteile und diskriminierung ist doch
die soziale macht auf unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen ebenen und ich will
es wichtig dass wir das im blick
behalten und der so genannte alte weiße
mann wird nicht im hinblick auf seine
weise diskriminiert er wird doch sie hat
nicht die schlechteren zugang zum
arbeits oder wohnungsmarkt
beispielsweise oder zu bildung und das
müssen wir unterscheiden damit wir in
dieser debatte voran kommen finde ich
nicht darf ich eine persönliche
erfahrung also ganz ehrlich du hast die
erfahrung nicht machen können ich habe
sie gemacht ich wollte die eingewöhnung
meiner tochter in der kita machen und
mir wurde erst am anfang verwehrt es
hieß wie der vater macht die
eingewöhnung gemacht die mutter ist das
jetzt nur ein vorurteil das fehlt es
nicht können oder das ist jetzt
diskriminierung ich merke es gibt vor
allem große uneinigkeit mit gewissen
definition von begriffen und vor allem
das treibt euch immer wieder auseinander
obwohl es viele dinge gibt die ja
eigentlich ähnlich sieht und wo er
eigentlich auch zustimmt viele probleme
die auch eigentlich gemeinsam anerkennt
auch wenn es dann wiederum kleine sachen
gibt die euch auseinander bringt wir
wollen jetzt tatsächlich über konkrete
lösungen reden und über kompromisse
da habe ich ein paar dabei punkt eins
rassismus beginnt im kleinen
wir müssen ihn bekämpfen bevor er in
radikaler vorm auftritt
beispielsweise sollten wir schon in der
schule sie heute auch häufig gefallen
kurse in antidiskriminierung
verpflichtend einführen können uns
darauf einigen wie würden sie nicht
einseitig ist global sind dann bin ich
dabei ich halte nichts von einem kurs
das muss gelebt werden von den erziehern
ich kenne viele themen
dadurch ist das kann das ist erstmal
erfuhr in den letzten halbwegs okay du
auch ihr habt viel das thema schule
angesprochen wir wollen nicht nur bei
polizeiaktionen da seid ihr da kurier
nicht also das ist ein thema für die
schule ist ja könnt ihr bei
ich glaube ein keine der großen probleme
die wir in diese gesellschaft haben dass
wir eine schulsystem die eigentlich viel
mehr auf bildung wert legt und nicht auf
sozialisation nicht auf wertevermittlung
nicht auf debattieren nicht auf
demokratische grundprinzipien und ich
glaube da muss unsere zukunft sein da
müssen wir alles tun damit die schule
der zukunft auch besser die chancen für
alle anbietet und bessere demokraten aus
den schulen hausherren beiden seiten
ich habe direkt die nächsten
lösungsvorschlag für euch der polizei
sollte man nicht mit verachtung und
hetze begegnen dann selbst wenn
rassismus ein strukturelles problem es
heißt das nicht dass jeder und jede
streifenpolizistin und jeder
streifenpolizist einem generalverdacht
unterliegen sollte
ich habe den nächsten lösungsvorschlag
für euch es darf im jahre 2020 nicht
mehr legitim seien menschen aufgrund von
äußeren merkmalen als verdächtig
einzuschätzen
studien zur erfassung von rachel
profiling müssen deshalb regelmäßig und
auf bundesebene durchgeführt werden auch
darüber haben wir führen gesprochen
stimmt ihr dazu bleiben wir verstehen
und ihr könnt einfach stehenbleiben
letzter lösungsvorschlag und ich hoffe
ihr bleibt jetzt einfach alle hier
es braucht einen ernst zu nehmenden
aktionsplan zur bekämpfung von
strukturellem und anti schwarzen
rassismus in allen
gesellschaftsbereichen dass das ist mir
zu wichtig dass wir nach nur das passt
nicht
ich rede von cobra ist ein haar ich bin
ein aspekt ja aber das mussten auch die
andere so dass allein reichten diese
allein ich war all die anderen
tanja damit kein problem
also es war natürlich eine sehr hitzige
diskussion mir ist natürlich bewusst
dass ihre in vielen aspekten euch nicht
einig geworden sind aber ich bin
grundsätzlich schön dass dieses format
dass dieses spiel jetzt zeigt dass man
einen konsens finden muss um überhaupt
irgendwie voranzukommen und ihr seid
alle gerade in der mitte und das finde
ich sehr schön deswegen vielen vielen
dank dass ihr am stadtbad und so viel
diskutiert habt danke ich glaube dass
man manchmal durchaus auch
unterschiedliche meinungen bis zum
gewissen punkt aushalten muss und dass
manche konsenses oder so aufeinander
zugehen das braucht man noch ein
bisschen mehr zeit ja wir müssen öfter
zu hören
verstehen lernen warum manche leute
ihren standpunkt haben erstmal ist es
positiv dass man im gespräch ist und
sich austauscht auch über die
unterschiedlichen auffassung ganz
entscheidend ist jeder ist demokrat hier
heute gewesen hat das auch sehr klar und
deutlich gemacht in der ausformung gibt
es da unterschiedliche sichtweisen und
einschätzungen deshalb ist es wichtig
dass solche formate auch gibt was mich
überrascht hat ist dieses hohe vertrauen
in die institutionen dass ich ein stück
weit natürlich auch habe ich würde mich
als demokrat fühlen aber meine
wahrnehmung sind irgendwie andere und
das also diese diese intensität des
vertrauens habe ich schon ein bisschen
überrascht ich bin emotional sehr
betroffen von den geschichten die heute
erzählt wurden und denke wie konnte die
lösung sein richtung gerechtigkeit und
bekämpfung von rassismus ich wünsche mir
für die zukunft dass meine tochter in
einer gesellschaft aufwächst vor alle
gleich sind unabhängig von herkunft
unabhängig von nationalität unabhängig
von hautfarbe oder religion
ich hoffe euch hat die erste folge
gefallen lasst uns hier gern kommentare
da wir freuen uns sehr mit euch zu
diskutieren hier könnt ihr unseren kanal
abonnieren damit ihr auch die zweite
folge nicht verpasst jo schück wird mit
der alten und der jungen generation
diskutieren außerdem findet ihr hier ein
weiteres spannendes video von zdf heute
und was jo schück und ich überhaupt mit
diesem format ihr erreichen wollen das
seht ihr hier
16 fragen nicht verpassen ab jetzt in
der zdf mediathek und auf dem zdf heute
youtube kanal